mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
wissens lust ihm viel vergnügen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ross & nadeschkin sind zurück in der
manege
vor 18 jahren sorgte das clown duo im
zirkus knie für lachsalven
ihre nähe zum publikum legendär die
reaktionen überwältigend und dieses jahr
keine panik corona machte im netz
schluss mit lustig kurz vor turnierstart
im september ist nun endlich premiere
mit strikten kurs ead maßnahmen für
ursus und nadeschkin ein hochseilakt
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz heute
sind wir zu besuch beim zirkus knie im
märz wollte der schweizer nationalzirkus
premiere feiern daraus wurde nichts der
lockdown kam dazwischen
doch jetzt am vierten september will der
zirkus knie hier in bern doch noch
premiere feiern natürlich unter ganz
anderen vorzeichen viel weniger
spielorte werden es sein und viel
weniger menschen im publikum die
ausnahme situation hält an und das gilt
auch für das schweizer claudio s &
nadeschkin sie sind dieses jahr beim
zirkus knie mit dabei wie geht humor vor
publikum mit masken und vor halbleeren
rängen darüber spreche ich gleich mit
den beiden
[Musik]
aber irgendwie ich nicht so lud das ist
wenig blöd sind ihr schau aber jetzt hat
es ja noch viel mehr jobs zu fuß holen
doch günter philipp es gab nur drei
super nanny und das original kmg und
esse ich hoffe gerecht bei 4 lange ob
das herz nur zwei buchstaben das aber
aber
note 2 aber da haben wir doch viele
buchstaben bringen nur was du zeit mein
knie und slk und sl zu genau
hallo ich mache ich habe ich hatte ich
könnte das was jetzt
ich verzeihe tanzen hätte ich plötzlich
mehr hersteller auf der schulter ja
mit dem könnte man die zirkus die habe
ich ein bild von links aber demokratie
die und jurist mit carlos schon sagen
sollst du jetzt haben wir mit einer
probezeit wirkt das sehr dramatisches
ohne netz und doppelten boden
es ist so als wenn man ich hallo auto
schweiz sind sie viel mühe in der
mannschaft standen die kleintier lecker
los und jetzt nach der langen zeit wie
gott so wir sind jetzt einfach froh wenn
es endlich doch noch los geht aber das
ist jetzt viel verunsicherung oder
freund los freuen ist es spieler
gleichzeitig hoffe einfach dass es
funktionieren will es einfach sieht dass
die show hoffen ist dass man merkt ja
wer einst probiert aber eigentlich gar
nicht berühren und rast mit den fall
dass auch normalen ist bild das publikum
bei wirklich zentrale rolle
ich habe das jetzt passiert zum teil
wirklich direkt mit dem publikum
interagieren oder man sagen objekt
vermutlich umgehend ohne zu wissen was
mir medizin dass teile stammen
desinfizieren produziert für die manege
kassel hat mehr hand mit dem bild
wählerschaft das duett die burgstadt
ausstoß publikum tore geht ausgewandert
und dass gott alles jetzt nicht oder
anders
oder eben nur beschränkt wie viel haben
müsse neu dank vom ursprünglichen
programm ohne job
wir haben noch nie die sache wirklich
neu geschrieben was man muss sagen ist
das mit dem corona ist nun verteilt wir
sind mit string und optischen normal von
moni lustig das heißt will der tcs dass
der virus mit os zugelegt ich das nicht
lustig ich kann nicht sagen durfte an
dem stoff inszenieren im nacken ich
neidlos die chronisch kreistages wird
thema sie aber mehr hat jetzt nichts
fiel dann das ständig wenn auf dem
momente wie ich glaube dir wo denn die
sind nur traurig und natürlich nur auf
dass sie gut dass jetzt alle masken und
spezielle situation aber irgendwie rum
jetzt läuft die show unterschätzen
andere behandeln
ja alle menschen über zwölf jahre die
ihn den kommenden wochen den zirkus knie
besuchen müssen während der ganzen
vorstellung eine maske tragen und so war
das auch vergangenen samstag in basel
als das stadtcasino feierlich wieder
eröffnet wurde
der konzertsaal für seine akustik
weltberühmt wurde erweitert und umgebaut
eine delikate aufgabe für die basler
architekten herzog & stimmen
man trägt maske bei der wiedereröffnung
des basler stadt casinos letzten samstag
die kleine schwarze
oder droht für ausgabe ton ihn tun
architekt pierre dämmerung bevorzugt ein
weißes modell
es gibt blauen osten und blau rote damit
man nicht vergisst in welcher stadt für
uns befinden hier feiert basel
und nachdem die türen endlich auf gehen
zum renovierten konzertsaal der in
voller pracht erstrahlt wird eines
deutlich es dominiert der schlichte
grünlich blaue mund und nasenschutz
bescheidenheit auch das typisch basel
so soll es auch sein denn nicht die
maskerade spielt hier die erste geige
gefeiert wird ein raum eine architektur
die akustik das orchester mozart die
ouvertüre zur zauberflöte wie zur
einweihung des stadt casinos 1876 hier
wurde geschichte geschrieben
1897 forderte theodor herzl auf dem
ersten kongress die gründung eines
eigenen staates für juden mitten im
zentrum von basel spielt die musik und
nicht nur das messen für dies und jenes
friseur wettbewerbe und allerlei
veranstaltungen prägten das image des
wurde politisiert protestiert und an der
fasnacht gespottet
das stadtcasino ein spiegel des basler
kulturlebens
doch irgendwann kommt auch ein gebäude
in die jahre
da bröckelt nicht nur die fassade
christoph flohr präsident der casino
gesellschaft erinnert sich die ganze
infrastruktur im musiksaal ich
altmodisch mang bewegt wahre könig haben
also alles müsse immer vorhanden ihnen
tragen wieder ausgetragen das ist sehr
aufwendig sei und die luftig ist es im
sumo praktisch unmöglich sehr konzert
betrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
doch nun ist es soweit fast 20 jahre hat
es gedauert von den ersten ideen bis zur
plüschigen vollendung vier jahre bauzeit
77 millionen franken teuer
entworfen von den architektur
altmeistern herzog und bewährung
zur großen überraschung etwas schlichtes
sie erweiterten den bestehenden bau und
schufen so einen palazzo im stil des 19
jahrhunderts
warum so ungewohnt bescheiden herr
herzog dass ich einfach die politik ist
hätte stabsgebäude ist und sein wird und
das man als einheit in maschine krachte
darum machen wir das sicher bald wieder
bis zum ersten mal dass der architekt
erhöht spruch von krankheiten nimmt und
trotzdem total modernes total sind
genetisch das ist nicht mehr verstecken
oder rational
die ersten ideen für das stadtcasino sei
noch ganz anders aus den
architekturwettbewerb gewann die
irakisch britische star architektin zaha
hadid wird einem monumentalen neubau
herzog tomorrow's erster entwurf kaum
weniger riesig landete auf platz zwei
doch dann der dämpfer saha dietz entwurf
war den baslern zu gewagt und wurde 2007
an der urne abgelehnt
über den neuen entwurf von herzog
dämmerung wurde nicht mehr abgestimmt
ohnehin wurde etwas mehr als die hälfte
von privaten mit zähnen finanziert
entscheidend war die zustimmung der
denkmalpflege den abstand zur
barfüßerkirche massiv zu verringern
wirklich frei mal begeistert von einer
neue gebäude das gefühl haben das ist
schon oder hoch stand
so jetzt vor das innere das foyer gibt
sich gar nicht bescheiden sondern bietet
die große bühne für den auftritt des
publikums raum zum flanieren und
parlieren weniger basel dafür mehr wien
oder sogar paris oder rom geht es im
begann zur schweizer team jetzt wirklich
erfreut über den namen verdienen
der stromstoß hörensagen nach
asiatischer pc wiener ballsaal
aber wie sieht die spiegel seite dampf
der spiegel sind ja nicht nur eins so
ein zwitter oder schreien spiegelt die
oberfläche aber die mindere hätten wir
den auch andere spiegel oberflächen das
eben doch sehr gut dass es sehr gedämpft
hatte und das ist schon uns immer
wichtig sind architektur die ganz
ähnliche palette wo mehr menschen können
sich überzeugend ist die akustik des
musik salz mit neuer belüftung mit neuer
bestuhlung mit fenstern die wie einst
ein außen schaffen und dennoch schuldig
sind
jeder einzelne tun und sei er noch so
leise soll hörbar sein wie viel mehr
realisiert dass im pianissimo wirklich
ganz null starten aber im vorteil denn
viel volumen und dann wieder ganz zurück
warum mir das nochmal die stellen
domenico milky way hat für die eröffnung
ein neues stück komponiert dass die
klangmöglichkeiten des saales ausreizt
es war ja ein stück für verschiedenste
perkussionsinstrumente im mittelpunkt
eine klangskulptur di domenico mit orly
eigens für diese eröffnung entwickelt
hat
clowns kultur sport wo im prinzips
musikalische grundmaterial die grundtöne
vor dem werk enthalte und die rhön das
musikalische material wird denn im
schlagzeug ensemble spielt so etabliert
sich das stadtcasino mit seiner akustik
als ort für innovative musik welten
auch eine neue komplett aus spenden
finanzierte orgel soll das basler
konzert leben bereichern
ein großer konzertsaal mit einer
wirklich berühmten akustik wie hier im
stadtcasino ist prädestiniert um
wirklich auch orgel musik darzubieten
die organisten thilo muster und babette
mondry haben den bau dieser besonderen
orgel initiiert denn die 4000
orgelpfeifen wurden aus zinn gefertigt
gewonnen aus nachhaltigem und
konfliktfreien abbau eine novität
genauso wie die neuen klangmöglichkeiten
der orgel durch den wind dynamisches
orgelwerke aus schaffte sache machen wir
bis zum spiel
meeresrauschen zum beispiel um das gibt
auch register wo je nach windhoek
versteht was ich gern
das haus ist bereit
auch architekt jacques herzog kann nur
noch lauschen jetzt voll arbeiten jetzt
wird das lebendig und machen sich
forscher
ich glaube etwas in der schweiz herum
geht mit vergleichbarer qualität der
musiksaal also klar akustisch und
architektonisch ist jetzt stimmt jetzt
wichtig ist das ist das gar nichts jetzt
der sie platz
[Musik]
hallo
aber die ist ja dass ich vorne quer
durch deutschland gar team studio sitzt
in der manege mitte haben nur am rand
und wir sind deutlich schweizer vorjahr
geordnet
der durst sind clowns und der labert vom
lachen ich habe das immer optimistisch
sie ruhig mag genau
es wäre doch immer vor der hand 800 lud
vor dass sie lachen gehört vielleicht
habe ich überhaupt kein problem mit ihr
sofort wird reagiert wenn der
fördermaßnahmen und natürlich froh es
müsste nicht alle masken allem aber mir
hat angefangen als straßenkünstler lang
ist's her uns erst am ufer du machst auf
die straße holen
das wesentliche hat er mir machen die
schlacht machen und langstrecke war mit
nummer blöde witze erzählen sondern
warnt lüth berühren mit dem und macht
und äußerst business sicherlich ein
bisschen schwieriger bereich will alles
passiert bei owschlag durch mehr an
blöd oder wir sind ja erfahrene zirkus
östlich vor 18 jahren sind wir schon mal
mit dem circus knie auf tournee und
trotzdem wird alles anders
in der arena einmal mehr das komplette
niña wichtig ist wie das new york
referent ob seiner mannschaft von damals
wenn wir heute natürlich dem ziel dass
ich das ohne waren sind stimmiger sich
so dicht es ist sonnenenergie und oft
ihr dürft nicht hoffe man muss weder
okay es ist wirklich zeit bis andere
metapher teil von einer historischen
events und der oktober viel routine und
sie planen mit musik 800 ab oktober und
dann wäre es schon fast als wäre die
niederlage wenn ich glücklich und mobile
du bist viel besser
das buch hat nur 850 ja während des
lockouts da haben wir vieles vermisst
ich am meisten meiner freundin zusammen
sein und gemeinsam an einem tisch sitzen
das fehlte ja wir wissen es nicht erst
bei corona gemeinsames kochen und essen
das nährt nicht nur den bauch sondern
auch die seele
obendrein kann es eine gesellschaftliche
sogar eine politische dimension haben
und das stellen aktuell gleich zwei
frauen unter beweis
ich bin sehr verfressen für die gegen
meilenweit beim essen gibt es keine
sünde wenn man bewusst und aufmerksam
ist was soll da die sünde sein
doris dörrie hat ein neues buch
geschrieben
die welt auf dem teller
auf rund 200 seiten erzählt sie sehr
persönliche geschichten rund ums essen
den knast zu ergattern
mit butter zu bestreichen und mit salz
zu bestreuen das war für mich schon
immer pures glück
ich war süchtig nach dem knust dieser
duft diese kruste
ich bin wirklich ein brot fanatiker wenn
ich meine finger auch ein burley bekomme
bin ich sehe ich euch das so phänomenal
findet diese harte kruste und das weiße
weiche innenleben ich finde es toll der
iaa präsentiert auf den ersten blick ein
leichtfüßiges buch die genießerin betont
das sinnliche das gemeinschaftliche
beimessen
doch die geschichten greifen tiefer auch
schon in ihren filmen hat sich der ihr
mit dem thema essen befasst
doris dörrie interessiert vor allem auf
der gesellschaftskritische und
politische aspekte in ihrem
dokumentarfilm tokio live porträtiert
sie den buddhistischen koch und zehn
meister edward s p braun der in seinen
kursen die kunst des essens aber auch
die kunst des lebens lehrt
und auch in ihren kolumnen verhandelt
sie beim kochen und essen das leben
alles ist veränderung wie wir wissen
der beste ort um veränderung zu üben und
zu studieren ist die küche welches
wunder ist es doch immer wieder dass
sich eine plumpe rohe kartoffel in
kartoffelbrei gnocchi verwandelt und
weiter
in der küche lässt sich kultur und
struktur einer gesellschaft ablesen was
bedeutet das denn in corona zeiten frau
dörrie das haben wir jetzt sehr sehr
klar gemerkt wie abhängig wir von
lieferung städten sind und davon auch
dass andere menschen sehr weit weg für
uns nahrung unbound jetzt in kronau
zeiten gab es eben dann auch diese sehr
dramatischen und tragischen verbindung
zum beispiel zu den erntehelfern in
deutschland die in so miesen
unterkünften leben dass sie sich
angesteckt haben oder jetzt auch die
metzger die großen skandale um die
großen metzgereien wo wir auch weil wir
billiges fleisch kaufen dulden dass die
arbeiter in so schlechten bedingungen
leben müssen dass sie sich dann jetzt
mit kommune angesteckt haben und diese
bedingt diese beziehung diese tiefen
verbindung die wollen wir nicht gerne
sehen und ich glaube aber dass bewohner
eine chance wahr und das wirklich auf
dem teller klar zu machen was es
bedeutet mit der ganzen welt über essen
verbunden zu sein
die stärke ihrer geschichten sie kreisen
um ernährungstrends klimasünden
lebensmittelindustrie
doch sie sind nie belehrend sondern
zeigen auf welchen einfluss unser essen
auf die gesellschaft hat und auf unsere
persönlichkeit
denn essen und kochen haben viel mit
identität zu tun
wie tief das rad das erforscht die
konzeptkünstlerin sandra knecht sie ist
auf dem land aufgewachsen hält selber
ziegen schafe hühner hunde und katzen
diese naturverbundenheit prägt ihr
schaffen
sie kocht professionell hat gar ein
dritter patient doch sie betreibt keine
landküche seit zehn jahren kocht sie für
die kunst
[Musik]
ich mache mit schmackes was man in der
hmi ford gemacht
das kann auch mal bitter schmecken wenn
die künstlerische symbolik
un-botschafters gebieten - objektive
realität und blick auf die waage bringen
das wandelt sich touren und eben wieder
das ist fluid und kreativität und dass
man eben moosheimer der verhandler wenn
sie nur einfach geil schon mit
globalisierung ist für mich mega sport
heimat und identität
ihre zentralen themen auch in ihrer
fotografien filme und installationen die
oft mit pflanzen und tieren und ihrer
verarbeitung zu tun haben
identität
heimat da geht es primär um
wohlgeschmack knechts gerichte können
ganz schön irritieren
bei den kunst happenings an denen sie
immer wieder experimentelles kocht und
serviert
da gab es auch schon mal ziehen hat auch
während ihrer kommenden ausstellung
mailand ist johlend im september wird
sie kulinarische happenings veranstalten
mit neuen gerichten die sie ihren
lieblings künstlerin widmet dieses club
sandwich hier soll die malerin miriam
cahn repräsentieren spezielle farbe und
die farbe wo sie hat sind auch viel wo
mir begegnet wenn ich bei uns im garten
oder war nicht im wald wie mit mini
geister das war für mich extrem
vielschichtig
sie schaue sehr präzis ideen wo sie
macht und audi überholt wo sie hat und
darum an ist es möglichst präzise
geschmack so können 100 töchter das ist
mir noch und noch etwas gewartet
wassermelonen weg
und blütenblätter dollar
sandra knechts geschmackliche porträt
der miriam cahn bon appétit er
beschäftigt über 200 angestellte aus
saterland hörning klink opfer
wie ist das ziel die letzte mühle das
ist ja ein komplettes namen zustand dass
ich sie aber wie große überraschung für
mich ist sie ein sehr viel südamerikaner
und die in locktow und die sind
diszipliniert und sie als allianz
sie sind natürlich sehr dankbar dass
hass und der schweiz sinkt sind als die
familie deine ist schon verrückt
existenzielle situation für den zirkus
nicht dass grundsätzlich glaubt auf
kurzarbeit gestellt
mir hängt kurzarbeit ab 1 euro
ausnahmslos auf einer piste und jahres
angestellt als er eigentlich möglich
aber natürlich kurzarbeit nicht alle
gäste über mich ein doch seit letztem
november dezember bis sie jetzt nur name
und nummer news gab ja sein dass die
finanzielle user sind mit chemie ändern
soll rooney krieg das einzige team
machen und so nummer eins nicht können
promobile beruft sich aber das ist
nichts problem sie weil die nummer sind
gestanden aber körperlich hat sich schon
müssen fit halten und sind viel
autorennen und so sagt er selbst der
circus knie der nacht vor der nähe zum
publikum die anarchie beziehung ganz
viele lied zum inneren zu ihrem zirkus
bei schauern ist das dass er überhaupt
möglich die nach herstellen
ich glaube nur wie sonst weil die werden
merken wie dankbar wir sind für jede
buchung
am vierten september feiert der zirkus
knie hier in bayern premiere und ist
unterwegs bis silvester durch die
deutsche schweiz nächste woche spiele
ich fußball mit der super kickerin sarah
kanji und gleich jetzt folgt hier auf
sf1 ein dokfilm über das minimalistische
leben weniger besitzen mehr leben ist
die devise
kommen sie mit leichtem gepäck durch die
woche
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
tourismus